PETER SZOLOVITS:
As David said, I've
been at this for a long time.
I am not a medical doctor.
But I've probably
learned enough medicine
to be able to play one on
television over the years.
And actually, that's
relevant to today's lecture
because today's
lecture is really
trying to set the scene
for you to say, well,
what are the kinds of
problems that doctors
are interested in by looking
at what is it that they do.
OK.
So that's our goal for today.
So what we're going
to do today is
to talk about, in a
very general way, what
are the goals of health care.
So how many of you are doctors?
A couple.
Great.
OK.
So fix me when I blow it.
All right.
Please feel free to interrupt.
So that's going to
be my first task.
And then the second
one is going to be
what are the things that
people actually do in order
to try to achieve these goals.
What is the practice
of medicine like?
What is the process
that generates the data
that we're going to be
using to learn from?
And then I can't resist
talking a little bit
about paying for health care
at the end of the lecture
because a lot of the
problems that come up
and a lot of the
interest that people show
in doing the kind of analysis
we're talking about in fact
is motivated by money.
They want to be able to
save money, or spend less
money, or something like that.
So it's important to know that.
OK.
Medicine's been around
for a long time.
I think from probably the
earliest of recorded history,
there are discussions
of people wondering
what the cause of disease
is, how to cure it.
They came up with some
fairly cockamamie theories
because they didn't have a
lot of scientific, modern
approaches to it.
But for example, this
is a photo on the left
of a shaman I think from a
Canadian Indian tribe who's
working on the boy
lying there who's sick.
And this shaman would use
his knowledge of experience
that he'd had with
other patients.
They did know a lot
about medicinal plants.
They knew something about how
to care for injuries and things
like that.
And so this was an effective
form of health care.
Not much record keeping.
You don't see electronic medical
records system in that scene.
On the right is a modern
shaman practicing at one
of the New York area hospitals.
And so there are
traditional cultures
in which that sort of hands
on interaction with the healer
is considered a
very important part
of the practice of medicine.
And if you listen to futurist
doctors talking about what
medicine is likely to be
like, they emphasize the fact
that the role of a
healer is not just
to be a good automaton who
figures out the right things
but is to persuade
a patient to trust
them to do the things that
he or she is suggesting
to the patient.
And there are a lot
of placebo effects
that we know from lots
and lots of experiments
that say that if you think
you're going to get better,
you are going to get
better, on average.
No guarantees.
OK.
Now modern medicine actually
looks more like this.
So this is an
intensive care unit.
And what you see
is a patient who
has got all kinds of
electrical leads, and tubes,
and things going into
them and is surrounded
by tons and tons
of equipment which
is monitoring him and
perhaps keeping him alive.
And so this is the
high tech medicine
that we think of as the
contemporary version
of clinical care.
Well, you might say, OK, what
does it mean to be healthy?
Right.
If the goal of medicine
is to make people or keep
people healthy, what is health?
So we turn to the World
Health Organization.
And they have this lovely,
very comprehensive notion
of the definition of health.
A state of complete physical,
mental, and social well-being,
not merely the absence
of disease or infirmity.
And then they categorize.
This and they say, well,
there's physical health,
there's mental health,
and there's social health.
Social health is
especially hard to measure.
And I'll come back to
that in a little while.
So what's easiest to measure
is how long people live.
And so we've had data
on survival analysis
for a long time.
And this is kind of shocking.
If you look here, this lower
curve is from around 1800.
And what it shows you is that if
you lived in India around 1800,
your life expectancy
was about 25 years.
It's not very good.
And if you lived in the richest
countries, which in those days
were typically
European, in Belgium,
your life expectancy was
way up there at 40 years.
Right.
How many of you knew that?
OK.
Good.
I didn't until I
started looking at this.
Now by 1950, which is
not that long ago, it
was like 69 years ago, in
Norway your expectation
was that you'd live
into your early 70s,
in the US that you would live
into your late 60s on average.
There was still a
huge cliff where,
if you lived in Bhutan,
or Somalia, or something,
you were still down around 30.
Today, well in 2012,
we're doing a lot better.
And the thing that's
striking is not only
that the people who were
doing well have gotten better
but that a lot of the people
who were doing very poorly
have also gotten better.
And so we're now up--
India, remember, was at 25
years of life expectancy
and now it's in the high 60s.
Now of course,
these are averages.
And so individuals vary a lot.
But it's kind of interesting.
So if you look at
the numbers, you
see that even on a shorter
term, there are big changes.
So for example, if
you're a male living
in Rwanda, which is among the
worst places in terms of life
expectancy, your
life expectancy,
if you were born today,
is about 62 and 1/2 years.
Right.
If you were born in 2001,
it was only 38 years.
Now what was going
on in Rwanda in 2001?
Genocide.
Yeah.
They were killing each other.
So that's sort of an
exceptional situation.
And that's gotten much
better because they've
stopped killing each
other as genocidal attacks
between the Hutu and Tutsi,
I think, if I remember right.
What about South Africa?
What was going on in
South Africa in 2001.
I'm not sure I heard you.
AUDIENCE: Failure to
address the HIV crisis.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yes.
The government at
the time was claiming
that HIV was not
the cause of AIDS
and therefore there was no point
in controlling HIV infections
because AIDS was caused
by something else.
Pretty crazy.
So that was terrible.
And they've gotten
much better at it.
So that's what you tend to see
in a lot of African countries.
And what you also see is
that there has really been
improvement everywhere.
So in the US, we went
from males expected
to live 74 years to almost 78
years, so about a four year
increase in life expectancy
over a period of just 17 years.
You women, by the way, are going
to outlive us men, on average.
There's some biological thing
that seems to work that way.
OK.
So a typical way
that people look
at the survival
of a population is
to say, well, given
a cohort of people
born at some instant zero,
what fraction of them
are still alive after a
certain period of time?
And what you see
is that, of course,
2031 we haven't reached yet.
And so these are
projections based
on sort of theoretical
extrapolations of actual data.
But the older data is real.
And what you see is that
from 1851 to, you know,
2011 let's say, these
numbers have gone way up.
Now where have they
gone up the most?
Well, it used to be that
childhood mortality was
enormous.
And so if you look at 1851, by
age 10 about 30% of children
had died.
And so we've gotten a lot
better at stopping that
from happening.
People also look at
curves like this.
So this is a distribution
of death rates by age.
This happens to be for
Japan a few years ago.
And again, females
do better than males.
The gold curve in the middle
is the average of the two.
And this is very typical
of almost any country
that you look at.
The shape of this curve
is pretty universal.
So what does this say?
It says that when you are born,
there is a relatively high risk
that you're going to die.
So these are kids who have
congenital abnormalities,
have prenatal problems, have
all kinds of difficulties.
And they don't make it.
So there's a fairly high
death rate at birth.
But once you make it to, I
think, about two years old,
the death rate is down to
about one in 10,000 per year.
Right.
And then it stays quite low
until you become a teenager.
Now why might the death rate go
up when you become a teenager?
Well, suicide is the
extreme example of that.
But teenagers tend
to be risk seeking
rather than risk averse.
You know, they
start driving cars.
They go skiing,
skydiving, whatever
it is that they're doing.
And they start dying.
But then if you
make it to about 20,
then there is a relatively
flat region where by then
you've developed enough sense
to know what risks are worth
taking and which ones aren't.
And so it's relatively flat
until about age 35 or 40
at which point it starts
inexorably rising.
And of course, as you
get older and older,
the probability that you're
going to die in the next year
becomes higher and higher.
Right.
This is uncomfortable
for somebody
with my amount of gray hair.
Now there is a peculiarity
in Japan which people
puzzled over for a while.
And that is that weird
dip up at age 106.
So first of all, that's a
very small number of people
that that represents.
And it turned out
that it was fraud.
So there were
families who failed
to report the death of
their ancient grandmother
or great-grandmother
because they wanted
to continue collecting
social security
payments from the government.
So that's an artifact.
OK.
Now this is a
serious problem which
we're going to return to in
a more technical way later
in the semester, which is
this problem of disparities.
So if you look at, for
example, the difference
between white and black
female life expectancy
in the United States, you
see that everybody's life
expectancy, as we've shown,
is going up gradually
in this case from 1975 to 2015.
But there continues to be a gap
between black and white females
and between black
and white males
where black patients
are more likely to die
or less likely to survive longer
given the disparities that
exist socioeconomically.
Maybe medically.
We don't know exactly.
And then if you
look at Hispanics,
however, they do pretty well.
So in 2015, you're
actually a little bit
better off to be Hispanic,
either male or female,
than you are to be
either white or black.
But it's still worse to be black
than to be white or Hispanic.
Right.
So these are the
kinds of facts that
drive some of the issues in
what we do in medical care.
Now what do people die of?
Well, about a quarter of
them die of heart disease.
And a little over a fifth
of them die of cancer.
This is USA data from 2014 so
it's not completely up to date
but hasn't changed that much.
And then there's a
decreasing number
of deaths from
various other causes.
So heart disease,
cancer, or chronic
lower respiratory disease.
So this is like
COPD that's caused
by smoking, stuff like that.
Accidents account for
about 5% of deaths.
Stroke, cerebral vascular
events, Alzheimer's disease,
diabetes, influenza, pneumonia,
kidney disease, suicide,
and then everything else
is about another quarter.
OK.
Now take a look at those.
What kind of diseases
are these, the biggies?
Well.
They're chronic.
Most of them are chronic.
They're also not infectious.
But except for
influenza and pneumonia,
nothing else there is
infectious as far as we know.
I mean, yeah.
That asterisk you should
put after every statement
about current medicine.
So that's interesting, because
if you wrote the same table
back in 1850, you would
find that a lot of people
were dying of infections.
And they weren't
typically living
long enough to develop these
lovely chronic diseases
of the aging.
So there have been
big changes there.
Now the other thing
that's worth looking at
is, in addition to the
reasons that people die,
they start getting sicker.
And they are getting sort
of less value out of life
because they're developing
all these other conditions.
So if you look at people
over 65, about half of them
have some form of arthritis.
And about 40%-- yeah.
About 40% have hypertension.
By the way, if you
have trouble with any
of the medicalese
words, just interrupt.
Hypertension is
high blood pressure.
Hearing impairment.
Me, I'm wearing a
hearing aid on one side
because my ears are going bad.
Heart disease, about a quarter.
Orthostatic impairment--
that means people who wobble
because their sense of
balance is not so good--
16%.
Cataracts, chronic
sinusitis, visual impairment,
genitourinary problems,
diabetes, et cetera.
So these are all growing.
Here's the list of the next 10.
And varicose veins, hernia,
hemorrhoids, psoriasis,
hardening of the arteries,
tinnitus, corns, calluses,
constipation, hay fever, and
cerebral vascular problems.
All right.
So people develop these by
the time they're over 65.
So one question we
might ask is, well,
what is the quality of life?
So for example, a
lot of the doctors
that I started working
with in the 1970s
were great advocates
of the application
of decision analysis
decision theory
to making medical decisions.
And so the problem is how
do you evaluate an outcome?
And they said, well, the way
we evaluate an outcome is
we look at your longevity.
Obviously, the longer you
live, the better typically.
But we also look at your quality
of life during that time.
And we say that if you're
confined to a wheelchair,
let's say, your quality
of life might not
be as good as if you
were able to run around,
or if you're suffering
from chronic pain,
your quality of life
might not be as good as
if you were pain free.
And so we came up with
this model that says,
well, the value of your life
is essentially an integral
from time zero to
however long you're
going to live of
a function Q that
says this is a measure of
how good your quality of life
is at that particular point
in time and then some discount
factor.
Right.
So what's the role of
the discount factor?
Well, it's just
like in economics.
If I offer you some
horribly painful thing
today versus 10 years from now,
which are you going to choose?
Most of us will say later.
So that's what the
discount factor does.
Now who knows what the
right discount rate is?
So in some of their work,
they were doing crazy things
like taking the financial
discount factors about bank
interest rates and
things like that
and applying them to
these health things
just because they didn't have
any better numbers to do.
That seems a little suspicious.
But nevertheless,
methodologically, it's
a way of doing it.
OK.
So how do you measure
the quality of life?
Well, there is this notion of
the activities of daily living.
So can you bathe and shower?
Can you brush your teeth
and groom your hair?
Can you get dressed?
Can you go to the toilet,
clean yourself up?
Are you able to walk,
get in and out of bed,
get in and out of a chair?
Can you feed yourself?
And then there are a bunch of
instrumental factors, things
like are you able
to clean your house
and can you manage
your money and so on.
So these are typically
for older people.
But they are ways of trying to
quantify that quality of life
by saying how many of these
things are you able to do.
And there are a lot of
federal regulations,
for example, that take advantage
of quantification like this.
So if you're asking to be put
on some sort of disability
where the government sends
you a check to keep you alive,
you have to demonstrate
that you are
at a certain point
on the scale that's
derived from these
capabilities in order
to justifiably get that.
So occupational therapy
is one of the things
that people try to
teach the elderly.
My parents died in their
late 80s and my dad was 90.
And I remember when he would
have some medical problem,
then he would be put
into the clutches
of an occupational therapist
who would try to make sure
that he was able to communicate,
and get around, and not
fall for tricks where people
wanted to get him to send all
his money to them,
or meal preparation
and stuff like that.
So these are sort of the--
occupational is a
funny term for it,
because this typically
applies to people
who are retired so it's
not really an occupation.
But it's the sort
of things that you
need to do in order to be
able to have a decent life.
Well, now there's an
interesting valuation question.
So if you look at
the top right model,
we actually don't have very
good data on anything other
than mortality.
So mortality is who dies.
So the blue curve
there is the curve
that you've seen before,
which is, of a cohort,
how many people are still
alive after a certain number
of years?
The red curve is
a morbidity curve
which says how many of those
people are still alive and have
no sort of problematic
chronic diseases.
So they're not in constant pain.
And they're not immobilized.
And they're not unable to
do the things that I just
listed on the previous slides.
And then disability
is when you really
become incapable of
taking care of yourself.
And it typically involves
moving into an assisted living
facility, or a nursing home,
or something like that, which
is kind of a nightmare
for many people
and also very
expensive for society.
So as I said, the
blue curve there
is based on actual data for
American females in 1980.
The red curve is a
hypothetical curve
where I just assumed that the
rate of developing a morbidity
is about twice
the rate of dying.
And the green curve I
assumed that the rate
of developing a disability is--
I can't remember-- I think
three times as high as the rate
of dying, something like that.
So that's why those
curves are lower.
And they look
approximately right.
But we don't have
good data on those.
Now the question
that you have to ask
is, how do you want
to change this?
So for example, suppose that
we kept the same situation.
We reduced mortality to
20% of its actual rate.
But we kept the disability
and morbidity rates the same
as they are on the top left.
So what would that do?
Well, what that would do
is create a huge number
of people who are
disabled because they're
going to live longer
beyond the point
where they're able
to function fully.
So this is-- yeah.
AUDIENCE: Can I just ask,
why does green not just
mean healthy?
To me, it just seems--
PETER SZOLOVITS: Green
just means healthy.
AUDIENCE: OK.
It does.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Yeah.
So beyond green is what I
meant is the morbidity curve.
And beyond red is
the disability curve.
OK.
I may have misspoken.
So green is healthy.
Red means suffering
from some morbidity.
And blue means disabled.
So if we just extend life but
we don't make it any better,
then that's not a very
attractive picture.
So other possibilities are
compression of morbidity.
So for example, if we reduce the
rate at which people get sick
and die but we increase it--
we decrease it initially
and then increase it
so that, on average, people live
about the same length of time
that they now do, then we're
going to have fewer people who
are suffering from
morbidity or who
are disabled because you last
doing well and then you die.
So this is the
wonderful one horse shay
where everything falls apart at
once, which, you know, frankly,
as somebody who's a
little closer to the end
than you guys are, I wouldn't
mind that kind of exit.
Right.
I don't want to be
disabled for 20 years.
I'd rather live a
long time healthy
and then drop dead
at some point.
OK.
My dad used to say
that he wanted to die
by being hit by a meteor.
Right.
He wouldn't know it's coming.
It's instant.
No suffering, no pain.
Perfect.
He almost got it but not quite.
OK.
And then the final story
is lifespan extension,
which is where we simply lower
the mortality rate and all
the other rates in proportion.
And what happens
is that you start
having healthy 107-year-olds
and not so healthy
120-year-olds in the
population in larger numbers
than we do now.
OK.
Social quality of life.
That's a tough one.
All right.
So here's a naive theory.
We take the quality of life
of every person on the planet
and we sum them up.
And we say, OK, that's the
social quality of life.
Is that a good idea?
Probably not.
Right.
For one thing, it
would say that we
ought to have as much population
explosion as possible,
because then we'd have more
people to integrate over,
which doesn't seem sensible.
Right.
Now obviously if we start
packing the world so that it's
super crowded, then
the quality of life
will go down eventually
enough that adding more people
is probably not optimal.
But nevertheless, that doesn't
seem like a real satisfying
solution.
How about less?
It was popular
about 10 years ago
for people to write these
sort of speculative books
about how would the world
look if half the people died.
Right.
Other than the
trauma of the half
the people dying,
you know, they were
proposing that this would
be some wonderful sylvan
sort of ideal old
fashioned kind of world.
I didn't buy that.
And of course, we don't
know of a good way
to get there,
although it is true
that in at least
developed countries,
birth rates keep falling to
the point where populations are
worried about underpopulation.
The Japanese, for example,
have very strict immigration
policies so you
can't become Japanese
if you're not born Japanese.
And Japanese people
aren't having enough kids
to replace themselves.
And so the natural population
of Japan is falling.
Italy is in the same
quandary except that Italy
has all these immigrants
coming in and trying
to become Italians.
And of course, this leads to big
political fights about who gets
to be an Italian
and who doesn't.
And then, of course,
there's the question
of money, which as I say
we'll return to later.
Now one other important
thing to consider
is that because of the
increase in life expectancy,
there has been a big change
in timescale in the way
people think about medical care.
So it used to be long,
long ago in the shaman era,
you wouldn't go to a shaman
to say keep me healthy.
You would go to a shaman saying,
you know, I broke my arm,
or I have this pain in my
leg, or fix me somehow.
And so things were focused
on the notion of cure.
And that was applicable
to acute illnesses.
But as we've gotten
better at treating
acute illnesses--
which, by the way,
didn't happen all that long ago.
I mean antibiotics
were only invented
in the early 20th century.
And that made a huge
difference in stopping people
from dying of infections.
So then it became more a
matter of managing long term
chronic illnesses.
And that's pretty
much where we are now.
The medical world at the
moment, most of the action
is in trying to understand
things like diabetes,
and heart disease,
and cancer, and things
like that that develop
over a long time.
And they don't
kill you instantly
like infectious diseases did.
But they produce a real burden.
And then, of course, the next
step that everybody expects
is, well, how do
we prevent disease?
So how can we change
your exposures?
How can we change
your motivation?
How can we change your diet?
How can we change whatever
it is that we need to change?
How can we change your
genes to prevent you
from developing these
diseases in the first place?
And that's sort of the future.
OK.
So that's about what
medicine tries to do.
But how does it do it?
And so we're going
to talk a little bit
about the traditional tasks that
are attributed to health care
practice.
So traditionally, people talk
about diagnosis, prognosis,
and therapy.
So diagnosis-- I
go to my doctor.
I say, doc, I've got
this horrible headache.
I've had it for two weeks.
What's wrong with me?
And his job-- in my case,
it happens to be a "he."
His job is to come
up with an answer.
What's wrong with me?
Prognosis is he's
supposed to predict
what's going to happen to
me, at least if he doesn't
do anything.
So is this headache
going to go away
or is it going to turn out
to be a brain tumor that
will kill me, or is it going
to be some amoeba that's living
in my brain and eat my neurons?
All kinds of horrible
things are possible.
So it's the prospect of
recovery as anticipated
from the usual course of disease
or peculiarities of the case.
And then therapy, of course,
is what do you do about it.
And prognosis is definitely
informed by diagnosis,
because if you don't know
what's wrong with me,
then it's much harder to predict
what's going to happen to me.
And if you can't predict
what's going to happen to me,
then it's much
harder to figure out
what to do to prevent
that from happening
or to encourage that
to happen, right?
So this is kind of
a serial process.
And the way I look
at it is that there's
a kind of cyclic
process of care.
And the process starts with
an initial presentation.
So I show up at
my doctor's office
and I complain about something.
And if you ever listen
to a doctor interacting
with a patient, the first
time the patient comes in,
the first question is always,
what brought you here?
Right?
And that's called the
presenting complaint.
So if I say, you
know, my ankle hurts
like hell, that's very
different than if I say,
I stopped being able to
hear in my right ear,
or I have this horrible skin
rash on my arm, or whatever.
And that's going to take me
in very different directions.
So then what happens is
that the doctor examines you
and generates a bunch of data.
So these are measurements.
And of course, it used to be
that those measurements were
based on observation.
So there are very famous
doctors from 100 years ago
who were spectacularly good at
being able to look at a patient
and figure out what's
wrong with them
by being very astute observers--
the Sherlock Holmes
kind of subtle,
oh, I see that you have a cut
on the inside of your shoe,
which means you must have
been going through brambles,
and you know, whatever.
I'm making up a Sherlock
Holmes story here.
So that generates data.
And then we interpret
that data to generate
some kind of information
or interpreted data
about the patient.
And based on that, we
determine a diagnosis.
Now, do we determine
a diagnosis?
Maybe not.
Maybe we guess a diagnosis.
One of the things I learned
early on working in this field
is that doctors are actually
quite willing to make guesses,
because it's so useful to
believe that you understand
what's going on.
If you say, well, there's
some probability distribution
over a vast number of
possible things, that
doesn't give you very good
guidance on what to do next.
Whereas if you can
say, oh, I think
this patient is developing
type 2 diabetes,
then you're locked
into a set of questions
and a set of approaches
that you might try.
Now, when we come back to
looking at machine learning,
machines don't have the
same limitations as people.
And so for a machine to
integrate over a vast number of
possibilities is not difficult.
But for a human cognition to do
that is very hard.
And so this is actually an
important characteristic
of the way doctors think
about diagnostic reasoning.
So then, having made a
diagnosis or made a guess,
they plan some kind of therapy.
They apply that therapy,
and then they wait awhile
and they see what happened.
So if your diagnosis led
you to a choice of therapy,
you gave that therapy to
the patient and the patient
got better, then you
say, well, it must
have been the right diagnosis.
If the patient
didn't get better,
then you say, well, how did
what happened to the patient
differ from what I expected
to happen to the patient?
And that drives your revision
of this whole process.
So we again examine
what happened
as a result of the therapy.
We gather more data.
We interpret it.
We come up with the revised
diagnostic hypothesis.
We come up with a
revised therapeutic plan,
and we keep going
around the cycle.
Now, that cycle
happens very quickly
if you're a hospitalized
patient, because you're there
all the time.
You're available.
They're trying to do
things to you constantly.
And so this cycle happens on
the order of hours or a day,
whereas if you were
an outpatient, then
you're not dealing with
some urgent problem.
It may happen over a
much slower period.
It may be that your
doctor says, well,
we're going to
adjust your drug dose
and see if that helps bring
down your cholesterol,
or manage your pain, or whatever
it is that he's trying to do.
Or worse yet, we're
going to try to convince
you to eat more healthy food,
and six months later we'll
see if your hemoglobin
A1C came down, that you're
less close to being diabetic.
So the time scale
is very different.
But that process of continually
reinterpreting things
is a really critical feature, I
think, of all of medical care.
And if you look back,
Alan Turing actually
talked, in the early
1950s, about health care
as being one of the
interesting application areas
of artificial intelligence.
Why?
Well, because it was
an important topic.
And he had the vision
that says, as we
start getting more
data about health care,
we're going to be able to
build the kinds of models
that we're going to be
talking about in this class.
But a lot of the early work took
a kind of one-shot approach.
So they said, well,
we're going to solve
the diagnostic problem.
So we're going to take a
snapshot of a patient, all
their data at a
particular moment.
We're going to feed
it into an algorithm.
It'll come up with a diagnosis.
We're done.
And that wasn't very
useful, because it
didn't obey the cyclic nature of
the process of providing health
care.
And so this was a revolution
that started, really,
around the 1980s when people
realized that you have
to be in it for the
long-run and not for sort
of single interactions.
OK, well, this is
just some definitions
of these care processes.
So here I've listed some ideas
that came from a 1976 paper
by several of my
colleagues, who said, well,
here's a cognitive
theory of diagnosis.
From the initial complaints,
guess a suitable hypothesis.
Use the current
active hypotheses
to guide questioning--
so to order more tests, to
ask questions of the patient.
And it's the failure
to satisfy expectations
that's the strongest clue to how
to develop a better hypothesis.
And then the hypotheses
could be in an activated,
deactivated, confirmed,
or rejected state.
They actually built
a computer program
that implemented this theory
of diagnostic reasoning.
And these rules, essentially,
about whether to activate,
deactivate, confirm,
or reject something
could be based both
on logical criteria
and on a kind of very
bad probabilistic model.
So it was very bad,
because what they really
needed was Bayesian networks.
And those were about a decade
in the future at that point.
So they and every other
system built in the 1970s
had really horrible
probabilistic models,
because we didn't understand
how to do it correctly.
Now, what's interesting
is somebody noticed
that if you strip away
the medicine from this,
this is kind of like the
scientific method, right?
If you're trying to
understand something,
you form a hypothesis.
You perform an experiment.
If the experiment is consistent
with your expectations,
then you go on and you've gotten
a little bit more confident
in your hypothesis.
If your experiment
is inconsistent
with your expectations, then
you have to change your theory,
change your hypothesis.
You go back and gather more
data, and then keep doing this
until you're satisfied
that you've come up
with an adequate theory.
So this was a
surprise to doctors,
because they thought
of themselves more
as artists than as scientists.
But in a way, they
act like scientists,
which is kind of cool.
All right, this doesn't
stop with caring
for a single patient.
So we have all these meta-level
processes about the acquisition
and the application of
knowledge about education,
quality control and process
improvement, cost containment,
and developing references.
So this is a picture
from David Margulies,
who was chief information
officer at Children's Hospital
here.
And the cycle that I described
is the one right here.
This is the care team
taking care of a patient.
But of course at some point,
that patient is discharged.
And then they're in
community care and self-care,
and then maybe they're in some
sort of active health status
management.
And then if that goes
badly, then there's
some episode where they
reconnect to the health care
system.
They get authorized
to come back.
They get scheduled for a visit,
and they're back in the cycle.
And so the process
of care involves
people going to the
hospital, getting taken
care of, they get better,
they get discharged,
they live their
lives for a while.
Maybe they get sick again.
They come back.
And so there's this larger
cycle around that issue.
And then around that are all
kinds of things about health
plan design and membership
and what coverage
you have and so on.
And then I would add
one more idea, which
is that if you have
a system like this,
you actually want to study,
at the next meta-level,
that system, make
observations about it,
analyze it, model it,
plan some improvements,
and then intervene in the system
and observe how it's working
and try to make it better.
So in terms of tasks that are
important for us in this class,
this class of tasks is
central, because one
of the things we're
trying to do is
to look at the way
health care works
and to figure out
how to make it better
by examining its operation.
And that can be done at
any of these three levels.
It can be done in the
more acute phase, where
we're dealing with
somebody who's
in the middle of an illness.
It can be done at the larger
phase of somebody who's
going through the cycle
of being well for a while
and then being sick, and then
being well again and being sick
again.
And it can be in terms
of the system itself,
of how do you design a health
care system that works better
for the population?
So this notion of a
learning health care system
is now a journal.
So in 2017, Chuck Friedman
at the University of Michigan
started this new journal.
And it's full of articles
about this third level
of external cycle.
So how does the health
care system learn?
Well, I'll tell you an anecdote.
In the mid-1980s, I was teaching
an AI expert systems course.
And I had just come
back from a conference
of medical informatics
people, where
they were talking about
this great new idea called
evidence-based medicine.
And I remember mentioning this
to a bunch of MIT engineering
students.
And one of them raised his hand
and said, as opposed to what?
Right?
I mean, to an
engineer, it's obvious
that evidence is the
basis on which you analyze
things and make things better.
But it wasn't
obvious to doctors.
And so this was almost
a revolutionary change.
And the idea that
they fostered was
the idea of the randomized
controlled clinical trial.
So I'm going to sketch
what that looks like.
Of course, there
are many variations.
But suppose that I'm one of the
drug companies around Kendall
Square, and I come
up with a new drug
and I want to prove that it's
more effective for condition
X than some existing drug B.
So what do I do?
I find some patients
who are suffering from X
and I try very hard to
find patients who are not
suffering from anything else.
I want the purest case possible.
I then go to my
statisticians and I
say, let's design
an experiment where
we're going to collect
a standard set of data
about all these patients.
And then we're going to give
some of Drug A and some of them
Drug B, and we'll see
which of them do better.
And we'll pre-define what
we mean by do better.
So like, not dying is
considered doing better,
or not suffering some bad thing
that people are suffering from
is considered doing better.
And then the
statisticians also will
tell me, given that you
expect Drug A to be,
let's say, 10%
better than Drug B,
how many patients do you
have to enroll in this trial
in order to be likely to get
a statistically significant
answer to that question?
And then they do it.
The statisticians
analyze the data.
Hopefully you've gotten
p less than 0.05.
You go to the Food and
Drug Administration
and say, give me permission to
market this drug as the hottest
new cure for something
or other, and then you
make billions of dollars.
Right?
This is the standard
way that pharma works.
Now, there are some problems.
So most of the cases
to which the results
of a trial like this are
applied wouldn't have
qualified to be in the trial.
For example, we talked
about morbidities, about
the chronic problems
that people have.
Well, if you're dealing
with one disease,
you want to make sure that those
populations you're dealing with
don't have any of
these other diseases.
But in the real
world, people do.
And so we've never
actually measured
what happens to those people
if you give them this drug
and they have these
comorbidities.
The other problem is
that the drug company
wants to start making
these billions of dollars
as soon as possible.
And so they want the trial
to be as short as possible.
And they want it to be
as small a sample as they
need to get that 0.05
statistical significance.
So these are all problematic,
and they lead to real problems.
So I didn't bring any
examples, but there
are plenty of stories
where the FDA has approved
some drug on this
basis, and then
later they discovered that
although the drug works well
in the short-term,
it has horrible side
effects in the long-term,
or that it has interactions
with other diseases where
it doesn't work effectively
for people except for these pure
cases that it was tested on.
So the other idea, the
competing idea is to say, let's
build this learning health
care system in which progress
in science, informatics--
whatever-- generates
new knowledge
as an ongoing natural byproduct
of the care experience
and we seamlessly refine
and deliver best practices
for continuous improvement
in health and health care.
Wonderful words from the
Institute of Medicine,
now called the National
Academy of Medicine.
But it's hard to do this.
And the reason it's
hard to do this
is mainly for a very
profound underlying reason,
which is that people
are not treated
by experimental protocols.
So it's very important
in that sketch
that I gave you of the
Drug A versus Drug B
that there is a randomization
step where I flip a coin
to decide which drug any
particular individual is going
to get.
If I allow that decision to
be biased by my expectations
or by something else I
know about the patient,
then I'm no longer
doing a fair trial.
And of course,
when I collect data
about how actual patients
are being treated,
they're being treated according
to what their doctors think
is best for them, and so
there is no randomization.
I mean, if I went to Mass
General and said, could you
guys please treat
everybody randomly
so that we collect
really good data,
they would throw
me out properly.
OK, so we also need a whole lot
of technical infrastructure.
We need to capture all kinds of
novel data sources, which we'll
talk about in the next lecture.
And then we need a
technical infrastructure
for truly big data.
So just for example, Dana Farber
started about five years ago--
it's a cancer hospital.
And so for every
solid tumor, they
would take samples of the
tumor and genotype it--
multiple samples, because
tumors are not uniform.
So just storing that stuff
is a technical challenge,
and being able to
come up with it.
You've got three gigabases, so
about over a gigabyte of data--
from each sample,
from each tumor,
times all the people who
come in and have this test.
So you buy some big
disk drives or you farm
it out to Google or something.
But then you need to
organize it in some way
so that it's usefully
easy to find that data.
So today's technique,
today's prejudice
is what I call the meat
grinder story, which
is you take medical
records, genetic data,
environmental data,
data from wearables,
you put them into an
old-fashioned meat grinder,
and out come bits, which
you store on a disk.
And then you have all
the data from which
you can build models.
And that's what we do.
You're going to see a lot
of that in this course.
OK, the other thing that
medicine tries to do
is not to cure people
but to keep them healthy.
And this has been pretty much
the domain of the public health
infrastructure.
So if you go across the river
to the Harvard Medical area,
there are a couple of
big buildings, which
is the Harvard School
of Public Health,
and this is what
they're all about.
So they do things like
tracking disease prevalence
and tracking
infections, and worrying
about quarantining people.
They also do a lot
of the kind of work
we're going to talk about in
this class, which is modeling
in order to try to understand
what's going on in individual's
health, in the health
of a population,
in the operations of
a health care system.
So they're very much into this.
Now historically, I looked
back and it turns out
there's something called the
London Bills of Mortality
in the 17th century, started by
a gentleman named John Graunt.
And he was interested
just in figuring out,
how long do people live?
And so he came up with
these bills of mortality,
where he went around to
different parts of London,
talked to undertakers
and hospitals
and whatever health care
providers existed at the time,
and collected data
on what people died
and how many people were
living in that area.
And so for example, he estimated
that the mortality before age
six in the 17th century-- this
was a long time ago, 1600s--
was about 36%.
So if you were a kid, your
chances of making it to age six
were only about 64%,
so less than 2/3.
Kind of shocking.
In the 18th century,
people you've never heard
of-- and Linnaeus, who
you probably have heard
of, because he was one
of the early taxonomists
for biological and animal
species and so on--
made the first attempts at
systemic classification.
In the mid-1850s,
mid-1800s, there
was a Congress of the First
International Statistical
Congress.
And a gentleman named
William Farr came up
with an interesting
categorization that said, well,
if we're going to
taxonomize the diseases,
we should separate
epidemic diseases
from constitutional diseases
from local diseases,
whereby "local"
he means affecting
a particular part of the body
from developmental diseases.
So this is things
like stunted growth
or failure of mental development
or speech development,
and then diseases that are
the direct result of violence.
So this is things like broken
bones and bar fight results
and stuff like that.
So that was the
first classification
of disease in about 1853.
Note, by the way, that this
is before Louis Pasteur
and his theory of the
germ cause of disease.
And so this was a
pretty early attempt,
and obviously could
have benefited from what
Pasteur later discovered.
So by the 1890s,
which is post-Pasteur,
they came up with
a classification
that was a hierarchic
classification, 44
top-level hierarchies broken up
into 99 lower-level categories
and 161 particular titles.
And they adopted this
as a way of getting,
typically, mortality
data of what was it
that people were dying of.
And by the 1920s,
you've heard of ICD--
ICD-9, ICD-10.
So this is currently used as
a way of classifying diseases
and disorders.
The International List
of the Causes of Death
was the first ICD back
in, I think, the 1920s.
And then it kept developing
through multiple versions.
In 1975, ICD-9 was adopted.
In 2015, ICD-10.
And these are under the
control of the World Health
Organization, which is now a
UN agency, although I think
it predates the UN actually.
And then we have ICD-9
CM and ICD-10 CM,
are US Clinical
Modifications that
are an extension of the
ICD-9 and 10 coding.
And they are primarily
used for billing.
But they're also used for
epidemiological research.
And if you look at the Centers
for Disease Control, CDC,
they collect death
certificates like this
from all over the country.
And so this is a person who died
of a cerebral hemorrhage which
was due to nephritis, which was
due to cirrhosis of the liver.
And so you can use this
kind of data to say,
well, here's the
immediate cause of death,
here's sort of the
proximate cause of death,
and here's the underlying
cause of death.
And so this is the sort
of statistical data
that we now have available.
Now, do any of you watch
the PBS show Victoria?
Nobody?
You're not television watchers.
All right, that's pretty cool.
I was stunned, because as I
was preparing this lecture
and I had the next
slide, it turns out
this plays a role in
one of the episodes
that was broadcast about
a week and a half ago.
So in the 1850s, there was a big
outbreak of cholera in London.
And John Snow was
a doctor who did
this amazing epidemiological
study to try to figure out
what was causing cholera.
The accepted opinion was that
cholera was caused by miasma.
What's a miasma?
STUDENT: Bad air.
PETER SZOLOVITS: Bad air, OK?
So it's bad air.
Somehow, bad air was causing
people to get sick and die.
And several hundred people died.
Whereas Snow started plotting
on a map of the area in London
where these were concentrated
where everybody lived.
And what he discovered,
interestingly enough,
is that right in the
middle of Broad Street,
which is pretty much at the
epicenter of all these people
dying, was a water pump that
everybody in the neighborhood
used.
And that water pump, its supply
had become infected by cholera.
And so people were
pumping water,
taking it home, drinking
it, and then dying,
or at least getting very sick.
And he looked at this
and he said, well,
if we turn off that pump,
the epidemic will stop.
And he actually went to
the queen, Queen Victoria--
hence the tie-in to
the television show--
and convinced her that this
was worth trying, because they
didn't have any better ideas.
And they took the pump
handle off the pump,
and sure enough the
cholera epidemic abated.
Now, of course the underlying
problem was sanitation.
And they didn't fix that.
That took longer.
But what's
interesting is here is
a 2003 study of the
spread of West Nile virus.
So this is mosquitoes that are
biting people and infecting
them with this nasty disease.
And they actually used
very similar techniques
to figure out that
maybe this was coming in
on airplanes through JFK.
So mosquitoes were hitching
a ride on an airplane
and coming into the US.
We need to build a border
wall against mosquitoes.
There is also a very
controversial practice
that used to be used a lot by
public health officials, which
was to quarantine people.
And so there are
lots of examples.
Anybody's relatives come
through Ellis Island?
Must be a few.
OK, so they were
subject to quarantine.
If you were sick when you
arrived at Ellis Island
and they didn't know
exactly how sick you were,
they would put you in a
building and wait a month
and see if you got better
or if you got worse,
and then decide whether to
send you back or to let you in.
So that was a pretty
common practice.
There's a famous
story of Typhoid Mary,
who was a carrier
of typhoid fever
but was not herself affected.
Unfortunately, she was a cook.
And wherever she was employed,
people got really sick.
And eventually, the New
York Department of Health
forcibly essentially jailed
her in some sanatorium
in order to keep
her from continuing
to infect people-- it was a
very controversial case, as you
might imagine.
You don't have to
go that far back.
Here's a 1987 article from
UPI from The Chicago Tribune.
So Jesse Helms,
who was a senator,
was calling for everybody who
has AIDS to be quarantined.
So fortunately,
that didn't happen.
But the idea is still
around, to say, well,
we're going to stop this
infection by quarantining
people.
And then here's a recent
report about the Ebola response
in Africa over the
past few years,
when Ebola was ravaging
parts of that continent.
And their conclusions
are it's controversial,
a debated issue, significant
risks related to human rights.
Quarantine should be
used as a last resort.
Quarantines in urban
areas are really hard.
Mobile populations make it hard.
And this is the most
technical conclusion,
that if you're going to
quarantine a bunch of people,
you have a huge waste disposal
problem on your hands.
Because if you have people
who might have Ebola,
you can't just
take their garbage
and throw it out somewhere.
You have to dispose
of it properly.
OK, so the last thing I
wanted to talk about--
hopefully mercifully short--
will be paying for health care.
So I remember reading
about 20 years ago
that if you bought a
Chevy from General Motors,
they spent more money on
health insurance and health
care for their employees than
they did on the steel that
went into your car.
That's pretty amazing.
So why is this?
Well, essentially, there's
an insatiable demand
for health care, right?
Nobody wants to die, except
for the suicidal people.
And so if I'm sick, I want
the best care possible,
and I want as much
of it as possible.
Because you know, what
is more important in life
than continuing to live?
So we also have gotten better at
making drugs and better tests,
and so on.
I remember one MRI
machines became
popular about 30 years ago.
The state of
Massachusetts, for example,
had a commission that
you had to convince
them to be allowed to buy an
MRI machine for your hospital,
because MRI machines
were very expensive
and MRIs were, at that
time, hugely expensive.
And so they wanted to contain
the cost of health care
by limiting the number
of such machines.
Well, eventually
the costs came down.
And so we're doing better.
But if you read
the newspapers, you
see that drug therapy
is very expensive.
We have these wonder drugs
for rare diseases or cancers
that cost $1 million a year
to pay for your dosage.
And so there is a
high human motivation
to do this, and
not much pushback--
except from insurance companies.
But they just pass the cost
on in insurance contracts.
There's also waste.
So there are lots of
stories about half
of health care
expenses are spent
in the last year
of somebody's life.
Although, Ingelfinger, who was
the editor of The New England
Journal, gave a talk
here about 25 years ago.
And he said, you know, when
I was a practicing doctor,
no patient ever came into
my office saying, doc,
I'm in the last year of my life.
And so that was a
difficult criterion
to try to operationalize.
There are marginally
useful procedures.
The IOM estimated
that there are sort
of 40,000 to 100,000 quote
unquote unnecessary deaths
per year--
in other words,
deaths that could
be avoided by just being
more careful and a little bit
smarter.
Well, so the result of this is
that if you look at health care
spending as a percentage
of gross domestic product
from 1970 to I think 2017,
I believe, on this graph,
what you see is
one real outlier.
And that's the
United States on top.
So I've selected a few
of these just to look at.
There's the US on top.
France, Germany, a lot
of the European countries
are roughly at that
highest of the crowd level.
Canada is down there.
The UK is a little lower.
Spain is a little lower.
Israel is a little lower.
Turkey is the lowest
of the OECD countries
in terms of percentage of GDP
that they spend on health care.
So well, that's OK.
But maybe we're getting
more for our money
than these other countries.
And so there are
a lot of analyses
that look at stuff like this.
They say, well, if
we spend so much
money per patient
per year, what do
we get in terms of
the simplest thing
to measure, which
is life expectancy?
How long do people live?
And what we discover is
that in the United States,
we're spending $9,000
a year on patients
and we're getting a life span
of somewhere in the high 70s.
So this is 2015 data.
Whereas in Switzerland,
they're spending about $6,000--
so about 2/3-- and they're
getting 83 years or something
of life for the
same price, and so
on for all these
different countries.
By the way, this is
all from Gapminder,
which is a wonderful
data visualization tool.
And I don't have
time to show you,
but you can click
on individual lines
there and slide the slider about
what euro you're talking about,
and the data moves.
And it's beautiful, and
it's a wonderful way
of understanding it.
So there's an important
thing to remember,
which was taught to
me by my friend Chris
Dede at the Harvard
Education School.
And that is that it's not even
good enough to stand still.
So he suggested the
following scenario.
If you look at the
growth of productivity
over this period of
10 years by industry,
you discover that
productivity went up
by seven point something
percent for durable goods
and went down by something
like 2% for mining.
About 1% for construction.
Information technologies grew
by 5 and 1/2% or something.
So if you ask the
question, what happens
if the demand for
these goods remains
constant over a period of time?
And what you discover is that
because the more productive
things become
cheaper, they wind up
occupying a smaller fraction
of the total amount of money
that's being spent.
So your computer, your
laptop, is a lot cheaper today
than it was 30 years ago.
And so that means
that the amount
of spending that people do
on things like information
technology, at least
per item, is much lower
than it used to be.
And if in the aggregate it's
also lower than it used to be,
that means that something
else must be higher, right?
Because it sums to 100%.
And so what this
shows is that if you
spend 30 years at the same
rates of productivity growth,
mining grows from whatever
fraction of the economy
it was to something that's about
three times as big a fraction.
Right?
And if productivity
growth is better,
then that sector of
the economy shrinks.
So I think something
like this is
happening in health
care, which is
that there's infinite demand.
And health care is not
terribly productive.
We're not getting better
as fast as electronics
is getting better, for example.
So people have tried
doing various things.
"Managed care" was the
buzzword of the 1980s and '90s.
And they said, well,
what we're going
to do is to prevent
people from overusing
medical services by requiring
pre-admission review, continued
stay review, second
surgical opinion.
We're going to have
post-care management, where
if you're released
from the hospital
and you're in that
second of the cycles,
people will call you at home
and try to help you out and make
sure that you're doing whatever
is best to keep you out
of the hospital.
And
We're going to try
various experiments,
like institutional
arrangements, that say, well,
if I as a doctor agree to refer
all my patients to Mass General
rather than to the Brigham or
the BI, they'll pay me extra.
And they'll get some kind of
efficiencies from aggregation.
And so maybe that's one
way of controlling costs.
So leakage is the idea of
keeping people in-system.
And capitation is
an interesting idea,
which says that
instead of paying
for what the
hospital does for me
or what the doctor
does for me, we simply
pay him a flat fee for the
year to take care of me.
And that takes away
the incentive for him
to do more and more and
more to get paid more.
But of course, it
gives them an incentive
to do less and less and
less so that he doesn't
have to spend as much money.
And so it's sort
of a knife balance
to figure out how to do this.
But that's an
important component.
So if you look at the
evaluation of managed care
a long time ago,
what they said was it
helped reduce inpatient costs
by increasing outpatient costs.
So what it's done is
it's pushed people
from going to the hospital into
going to their doctor's office.
But it's been pretty much a wash
in terms of overall spending.
Doctors also hated managed care.
I was sitting with
one of my colleagues
at a Boston hospital, and
an insurance company clerk
called him to dun him for
having ordered a certain test
on a heart patient.
And so he was furious.
And he turns to her and
says, so which medical school
do you have your diploma from?
And of course, she doesn't
have a medical degree.
She's following some
rules on a sheet
about how to harass doctors
not to order expensive tests.
And so we have Edward Annis,
the past president of the AMA,
who says, well,
in the glory days
there was no bureaucratic
regimentation, no forms,
no blah, blah, blah.
And all my patients were
happy, and I was happy,
and things were ideal.
If you actually look
back at those days,
it wasn't as good as
the cracks it up to be.
And some of those
issues of disparity
that we were talking
about were horrible.
So for his patients
who were rich
and who could afford to see
him, life was pretty good.
But not so much for
underserved populations.
So you've seen ObamaCare come
and partly go, and continues
to be controversial.
But it's trying to foster
better information technology
as a basis for getting doctors
to make better decisions.
It's trying to foster these
accountable care organizations,
which is a version
of capitation,
to put the pressure on to reduce
the amount of health services
that people are asking for.
There is a hospital readmission
reduction program now
that says if you are a
Medicare patient, for example,
and you're discharged
from the hospital
and you're readmitted within
30 days of your discharge,
then they're going to
dun you and not pay you
for that readmission,
or not pay you
for part of that readmission.
But if you look at the
statistics, which I just did,
that's the distribution of the
payment adjustment factors.
So it turns out the
lowest number is 97%.
So a 3% decrease
in reimbursement
is something that the
CFO of your hospital
would really care about.
But it's not like a 25%
reduction in reimbursements.
So this has had a
fairly minor effect.
Let me just finish by saying
that money determines much.
From our point of view,
one of the problems we face
is that IT traditionally
gets about 1% to 2%
of spending in medical centers,
whereas it gets about 6% or 7%
in business overall and
about 10% to 12% for banking.
And a lot of these systems
are managed by accountants,
although that is
slowly changing.
So in the 1990s,
HST with Harvard
started a training program
for medical doctors
to become medical
informaticians-- so practicing
this sort of witchcraft.
And our first two
graduates, one of them
is now CIO at the
Beth Israel Deaconess.
The second one is CIO
at Children's Hospital.
And so one of my big
successes personally
has been to displace
some accountants
by doctors who
actually understand
this technology to some extent.
OK, I think that's
all I'm going to say.
There's a funny last
slide here, which
has a pointer that I would
want you to remember.
The slides will be
up on our website.
You can follow it.
MIT has a program called GEMS.
It's the General Education
in Medical Sciences, intended
as a minor program for
people in the PhD program
in some other field.
And if you're serious about
really concentrating on health
care, developing at least
the kind of understanding
of the health care process that
I've tried to give you today
and that would allow you to
play a doctor on television
is really important.
And there is a program that
helps you achieve that,
which I commend to people.
OK, see you next week.